this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode we're taking a look
back at some of the most cursed weapons
to have offended poor Jonathan in 2022.
oh Dave what have you done to this poor
innocent block 18 I mean what can I say
it's called the port of pooper 5000 I
mean do you really want an attempt at
serious commentary on this thing uh this
is a sort of extremely cursed P90 both
in its redesign and then of course
somebody has decorated it
foreign
and the whole team here at Gamespot just
want to say thank you to everyone who's
watched the show over the last year we
really appreciate your support and if
you enjoy this kind of content make sure
to keep an eye out for our new series
Loadout a show where we take a look at
the history and impact of some of the
most iconic weapons in gaming from the
sniper and lmg through to the M16 and
P90 Jonathan will be making plenty of
appearances over on that show too so
make sure to check it out right let's
take a look at some of Jonathan's pain
and torment from the past year
right what have we got here an M1 or
M1A1 Thompson with jungle mags that's
the least of this thing's problems we've
got a really weird well it's not that
weird Okay so let's be kind so the the
foregrip the wooden foregrip of the
Thompson has been replaced with a sheet
steel heat shield handguard that's
perforated that's a valid choice in a
world of limited resources the butt
stock is the real problem here needless
to say it is a boot it's not even a shoe
as the name would suggest so the name is
incorrect I don't know why you would do
that okay let's be let's be uh
charitable so it's the apocalypse you've
got the ability to fabricate some sort
of a buttstock for this thing but it's
not comfortable you've got no available
rubber blocks or ability to stitch
Leather So for a butt pad you just stick
a boot on the end of it what's really
throwing me off and make making my brain
hurt is what appears to be a
sliding left side cocking handle this
being the simplified version of the
Thompson it should have a right side
popping handle with a simple round
handle like you've all seen it shouldn't
be on the left side and it shouldn't be
a weird rectangular shape that looks
very familiar but I can't think what it
might be from and it's called the shoe
makuzi nine when it's not nine
millimeter it's 45 even in the game so I
don't know where the nine comes from I
don't know where the usually comes in I
don't know
because there's no easy on this
I don't know what it is about the poor
old Tommy Gun people cannot resist
putting it in space and this is quite a
nicely done one but uh I I'm not a fan
of neon and you know different colors
and yeah not not really my thing we just
saw a round of ammunition in the drum
there for some reason as well as the the
projectile bit having a glow to it so
it's got some sort of an effect the
prime is also glowing bright blue I
don't know why that would be the case
it's either an energy weapon or it's a
normal projectile weapon I would think
but this appears to be a mixture of both
making a making an energy weapon that
that Parks back to the Thompson I can
get behind that I'm not so big a fan of
modifying a Thompson to make it
futuristic but clearly it speaks to
Something in people because it happens
quite a bit
foreign
this is a sort of extremely cursed P90
both in its redesign it's inexplicable
maybe anime inspired redesign and then
of course somebody has decorated it so
it still has the P90 cocking handles the
version of the magazine catch the
magazine is weird I don't like that sort
of reverse Outrigger sight Mount I think
there's a reason why the P90 has the
bridge over the top of the receiver to
stabilize the sights uh the whole thing
just looks like a toy
foreign
just generic neon pink Mist when we hit
the enemy almost like some sort of
paintball effect I think the Tracer fire
as well I mean you don't get Tracer fire
out of firearms unless you put Tracer
ammunition in them but regardless for
this gun it's pink it's unspeakable
really
what's up
oh Dave what have you done to this poor
innocent Glock 18 at its heart however
it's one of these the Glock 18 c the C
stands for compensated and here is ours
or one of ours in its original
Tupperware style container uh with the
with the markings on it which is very
nice so when people call the Glock
tactical Tupperware they're not just
referring to the plastic frame well they
might be but uh it actually does come in
tupperware
now from what I can see under all of
this nonsense it's it's a good
representation of an 18c now I can't uh
hope to replicate the dubious agency
here but I happen to have a Surefire
light module here very simply fits to
the accessory Rail and makes this one
look a little bit more like the one in
the game now a light and in this case
laser module a very sensible accessory
for a modern combat pistol fully
automatic automatic capability and a 50
round rum less so
foreign
what can I say it's called the
portapoopa 5000 I mean do you really
want an attempt at serious commentary on
this thing I suppose you're gonna get it
I mean the thing looks like it's covered
in it doesn't it I don't know if there's
a clean version of this gun inexplicably
the yellow bits are clean and then the
rest of it is just brown maybe it's an
aesthetic I don't know all right let's
watch it
dick
well as we could have predicted
it's a sort of
flamethrower looking grenade launcher
that fires radiated shite
can I say this this is unusual even for
a Borderlands game I would suggest and
it just it defies interpretation that
there's I'm gonna try anyway there's
some sort of a vented nozzle like a like
a well like a weed burner really than a
flamethrower but you know reminds me of
video game flamethrower a a completely
pointless front sight there lots of
pipes and it's kind of punting out
explosive Radioactive
poo bombs I I tell a lie the front side
is not completely pointless it is for
use in conjunction with a really
terrible rear sight that has a weird
shape for no reason but at least you've
got something to line up your front
sight with I suppose and then yeah I'm
not entirely sure what's happening with
the rest of it seem to be re-coating it
with poop at one point
one of my favorite Firearms of all time
as some of you know the MP5 except it's
not now has the gun itself uh I've
grabbed something pretty similar here
mp5a3 and it happens to be in the same
configuration except for the lack of
rails on the forehand as the I won't
call it an Abomination because it's not
completely cursed but for an uh MP5 fan
like me it's pretty far removed biggest
issue for me would be the magazine well
area it's far too wide in reality it's
as wide as it needs to be to fit this
magazine
going along with that is the horrific I
don't know what I don't know what to
compare it to but a gigantic magazine
catch which sits here which is where the
real sort of secondary magazine catch
sits on the MP5 that nobody uses unless
they have a semi or us semi-automatic
only version like an HK 94 where that's
your only magazine actual users of this
thing use the
paddle magazine release which is not on
this gun so pretty disappointed with the
MP5 in Modern Warfare 2 2022
foreign
[Applause]
we see that the cocking handle is not
the HK shape it's not even the G3 shape
with the longer Leaf Ridge which this
doesn't need but anyway it's not bad
it's just a rod I mean you could replace
the coffing handle with a cylindrical
Rod like that but why would you it does
make it look pretty weird so we see a
version of the reload there where we get
a Fresh Magazine inserted we slap the
cocking handle to chamber the round
that's how you're supposed to use it we
then see a press check of the chamber
that's what you definitely don't want to
do with an HK roller locks system you
you don't have a means of forward
assisting that to make sure it's now
fully shut your rollers might ever so
slightly out of Engagement which means
the gun's not going to fire so you do
not want to be doing a press check on
this system
thank you
for one
right this this game is really taxing my
my brain which is probably an indicator
that I should switch it off so we've got
this thing and it's obviously a spin on
the old west Weaver action rifle they're
so complicated uh it's got a spiral
fluted bolt which someone has obviously
seen on like a high-end bolt action or
something and has incorporated that
because it looks cool doesn't really
make much sense on this and we've got
the John Browning bolt system that's in
the Winchester 1892 for example rather
than the classic toggle action it's not
quite the Browning action but it does
have the bolt that protrudes out the
back to [ __ ] the hammer so there's some
mechanical functionality going on there
and we can see the rounds conventional
looking they look almost like five point
steel cased 5.56 millimeter rounds
interestingly and they are held on a
leather shell holder that is part of no
sorry strapped to this very elaborate
wooden stock I'd have to say I like the
overall design the sort of black gold
and the dark wood it actually looks
pretty good to me it's just very busy
compared to a real gun and the the
cartridge is being held opposing each
other rather than go all going the same
way would make quick loading a bit
awkward and mechanically I can't really
figure out how it's feeding those rounds
there's there's a tube below the barrel
that would normally be the magazine but
it looks too short and not kind of
connected up to the mechanism in a way
that would work
Double Down okay in trying to figure out
if this thing is mechanically viable I
have spotted a weird Quirk of the iron
sights so it does have iron signs as you
can see looks like it has several it's
got a it's got a Groove in what looks
like a lot like a conventional tangent
site but it has the ramps for the
tangent on top of the tangent it's got
design elements of a real rifle site but
they're upside down and then so you
could use the the groove the notch in
the back of that as your site then
there's a sort of gold colored horseshoe
thing that looks like it could be a rare
sight and then there's a flip up front
sight with a round protector and a gold
post
sitting behind that and I can't see how
that would even flip up to act as a rear
sight and it isn't a rear sight because
it's a post
it really makes my brain hurt I think
all of that is just included because it
looks busy and interesting but it
doesn't make a lick of sense as far as I
can tell
foreign
revolvers gotta have a revolver in well
any game descended from Half-Life needs
to have a Magnum revolver in my view
regardless of how realistic that is and
of course we've got one faction who can
basically in theory buy whatever weapons
they want so what the heck the latest
version of Counter-Strike has a
modernized revolver with a picatinny
rail on the top well not really a muzzle
weight again it's a rail adapter on the
front this is one of the Smith Western
performance center models based on the
old school
series of revolver frames those haven't
really changed but the the barrel
profile the ability to mount Red Dot
sights on there once upon a time you'd
have needed a custom Mount to achieve
that and with modern revolvers this type
of revolver anyway you have a standard
picatinny rail on the top which changes
up the looks for the player as well and
lets you use a scope there's always been
something about a scoped revolver again
thinking back to that Half-Life Magnum
that was quite the Revelation in 1998
the Fanning of the hammer not really
necessary it's a double action revolver
as Shahs demonstrated in the animation
with a weirdly sort of clockworky
ratchety sound which you wouldn't
normally hear I'd worry if you could
hear the lock work of a revolver
clacketing away as you pull the trigger
uh I mean if you put your ear next to it
you'll hear it but speaking of putting
guns near your head
um
spinning it around the finger not
recommended not only is it sort of
pointless and the risk is you've dropped
the thing but uh spinning it in that way
means you're pointing the thing at
yourself whilst putting pressure on the
trigger and if you were stupid enough to
do it sort of extra stupid enough to do
it with the hammer cocked in single
action mode well you've got a very good
chance of shooting yourself or at least
someone behind you but I understand the
impulse to depict a revolver in Old West
style if you're going to do that though
I probably would have gone for something
like a red hawk or some Modern Magnum
take or bfr maybe modern Magnum take on
the old school Single Action Army and
then the Fanning would be worthwhile it
would look very cool and spinning it
around the finger would be a bit safer
in theory I know it's a game you're not
going to hurt yourself but
yes
yeah uh
the Burger Town classic
yeah what can I say
not much
vaguely horrific with the sort of meat
texture
so this is this is sort of the essay VZ
25. this is the Czechoslovakian Cold War
era submachine gun the 25 is in 9 by 19
and it has the 25 that is has this pull
and fold
and then press in the latch on the butt
plate section to latch it into place and
let it go so you can use that as a fork
grip the Call of Duty version is quite
different the front half is pretty close
the cocking handle is different it's a
completely different shape open bolt
operation it's got that right so then
the back half the stock is attached
almost like a like a well rod grip with
tabs and two screws not with this all
enveloping rear sight section here which
is a more robust setup and then this
rear sight that I that I don't like is
replaced by a standard aperture rear
sight with protectors on it so they've
changed up the back end of the gun the
proportions look different too other
details are changed I'm going to sound
like a broken record but if you're
trying to replicate an historical
firearm replicate it
foreign
what the heck is going on there so we've
we've opened up the gun that apparently
does fire bullets from a sort of a drum
mag at the back and we've shoved a
thermite grenade which I've seen being
used in the in the footage that gets
shoved into the action somehow even
though bullets have to get from the back
of the gun to the front of the gun so
I'm not sure how that would work and
then that is somehow superheating
something looks like the barrel is
getting super heated and then that makes
the bullets do thermite things
not a clue doesn't make a lick of sense
but it's quite cool let's see what
damage it does
enemy down right so the effect is fairly
subdued is not a great deal of
incendiary effect that I'm seeing there
it just kind of as it says on the
indicator there revs up your uh
conventional ammunition now regardless
of feed issues shall we say heat is a
massive problem for firearms now I'd be
less concerned about that if this game
didn't use conventional self-contained
metallic ammunition with brass cases if
it used some futuristic ammunition
system I could get my head around a bit
better I'm guessing the guns have some
sort of cooling system built into them
this one must because if your cartridge
gets red hot as we're seeing here you
know thermite's damn hot really really
hot that's how it works burns down
through things what happens is the round
goes off um you don't have to hit the
primer in the back of the case to set it
off if you leave it in a fire or shoot
it in a very hot gun this is this is why
machine guns are typically open bolts so
that there's air able to circulate and
stop what's called cook off where the
round just blows up because if that
happens before the Bolt's locked the gun
will explode do it damage potentially do
you damage so deliberately applying
super heat to your firearm is a bad idea
thanks again for watching if you enjoyed
this kind of content please make sure to
like this video And subscribe to the
channel as we'll have new episodes of
firearms expert reacts every Saturday
and new episodes of Loadout every Sunday
again please check out the links in the
description of the video if you want to
help support the Royal armories and
we'll catch you next time
foreign
[Music]